[Music]
hey guys it's justine and uh you might
notice i'm not in my current
normal everyday los angeles office i'm
somewhere different i'm on the east
coast and that's because i have been
trying to spend as much time as i can
possible with my family this year since
last year i hardly got to see them at
all so thankfully travel is open but the
work hasn't stopped so i've decided to
set up a mini east coast office here
in my sister's basement and this is
really fun because this video is
actually sponsored by hp instant inc and
i am
so excited about this because we
partnered together to surprise my sister
and my parents with a printer and an hp
instant ink subscription every time i've
asked my sister or my family i'm like
hey um i need to print something do you
guys
what do you oh you're out of ink oh your
printer's old i don't even think it
prints anymore and then my sister didn't
even have a printer so i actually have
an hp and sending subscription back home
in los angeles and i
love it so much because i never have to
worry that my printer is going to be out
of ink because if it starts running low
it tells hp hey justine has an hp
instant ink subscription
let's send her a box of some new ink
cartridges and what's cool
is you can choose the plan that works
best for you they have plans starting as
low as 99 cents and you choose how many
pages you think you're going to be
printing that month and you can change
these plans anytime if you need more
pages or if you need less pages it's
super easy super simple and
i am so glad that now i don't have to
worry about printing on the east coast
so whether you print a couple times a
month or several times a day it really
doesn't matter
you can pick the plan that works for you
they have plans ranging from 15 pages to
pages a month and every page counts the
same no matter how much ink you use when
it runs low
replacement ink cartridges will be
shipped to your home along with a
prepaid postage recycling envelope for
your used cartridges so if you guys are
interested in hp instant ink i'll put a
link in the description where you can
check it out and you may actually have a
printer that's already eligible for this
most hp wi-fi enabled printers
five years older or less should be
eligible for hp instant ink so
check it out and now my friends let's
start this office tour i keep saying
that i'm in a basement and the
perception of a basement to me like if
someone's like oh i've been working out
of a basement
is like a grimy dusty dirty dungeon
this is the complete opposite this is a
finished basement i mean she has like a
couch
set up a whole gaming station where her
husband plays his video games she's got
a bar
a freaking pool table and i have kind of
taken over this whole corner and jenna
has taken over the corner over there
there's a lot of space so i've even been
doing my lightsaber training
in here you know it's a basement but
like it's not a basement so the first
thing i'm going to show you guys is what
i'm
kind of filming on right now i'm filming
with my sony a7s3 and i have the 50
millimeter
g master prime 1.2 oh boy like this
kind of looks like one of those fake
like zoom backgrounds
but look no it's real any time i use one
of these lenses with the amazing bokeh
people on my zoom calls always think
that it's a blurred background i'm like
nope this is just um
high production a few months ago when we
made our first trek out here
i also decided you know what i'm gonna
just bring as much stuff as possible so
i even checked one of my aperture lights
which i'm using
and it's been so great it's like a
perfect key light i basically only need
this
and there's also some natural light over
here so it kind of fills everything in
nicely that
was all well and good until i realized
how many zoom calls and conference calls
and live shows and streams and
interviews and things that i was also
going to be having to do
from over here and at the same time
jenna was gonna have to be filming so i
went to uh
went to best buy and bought some of
these elgato key lights i love these
things so much because they connect to
wi-fi
i can turn the brightness down and i can
control all of that right here just from
my phone i'm sitting in my sister's
husband's gaming chair i don't know why
i haven't bought a gaming chair for for
me ever i've never had one and i don't
know why because this is the most
comfortable thing
that i've ever sat in this has been
actual game changing
for editing like i'm just like super
cozy
edit edit i kind of like i need this and
since i have the lights and i have the
camera i have a second a7s3 up there
that i use
and connect for zoom calls but most of
the time i've just been using the imax
eyesight camera no it's not i said
facetime i'm sorry hello i'm sorry i
have time traveled i just been using the
built-in webcam on the imac and this is
one of the new m1i max you guys saw that
i did an unboxing of all of the colors
and it's actually
been working out quite well because i
have been utilizing several of those
imacs i've left one here
at my sister's house and i've been using
one at my parents house and then jenna
has also been using one and then i have
one more set up running a beta version
of mac os monterey so i'm definitely
utilizing a lot of technology and then
continuing on to the desk we have one of
the elgato wave microphones
got the mag safe duo charger my old air
pods and of course the new air pods max
this mouse pad is made by nomad it looks
cool
and it's very functional this right here
is the thunderbolt dock
by owc and this is also a lifesaver i
need way more than two thunderbolt and
two usbc ports so this has been the
perfect solution for that so here's my
ipad pro and then behind that
you'll see i have two different rubik's
cubes i feel like the rubik's cube for
me
is what a fidget spinner is to a lot of
people who use fidget spinners for
um you know lessening their anxiety i'll
be sitting there on conference calls
just like
stressed about something and i'm like
okay all right solved i feel better
i also have this little stand here that
i've got my neon xbox controller and
then i can just put stuff in here and
right now i have a mobile tripod there
works for me and last but not least we
have the road caster i've actually been
checking this in my suitcase and just
using
a lot of clothing to pad it the amount
of things that i've checked in
my luggage that's not clothing i mean
i've brought lightsabers home
things that need to be unboxed like full
freaking boxes and i just use like my
clothes as padding it's like i don't
even care about the clothes i literally
wear the same thing
every single day it's like oh wow are
you gonna wear a different pair of black
leggings that look exactly like the ones
you were yesterday oh are you gonna wear
probably the same sweater that you've
been wearing for the same past 500
videos
yeah actually i am if steve jobs can
have a uniform
i can have a uniform so that kind of
does it for the desk tour it honestly
it's been
a challenge kind of filming in a new
location because obviously i don't have
tyler hi tyler who helps me shoot all
the time but definitely being out of
your comfort zone
when you're trying to work and shoot and
film is it's definitely
a struggle but i am really really happy
that i
have kind of a really great setup here
that i'm still able to make videos and
make content for you guys
anyway i'm going to print out some
photos now and i'm going to see
if my little niece can tell us who's in
the pictures
[Music]
hold on a second okay all right so this
is a printer
and we have hp instant ink so when you
are older you're never gonna have to
worry about
running out of ink have you seen one of
these before okay sit down
look at these pictures that we just
printed who's that
jessie that's right that's me three
people are you ready to do this one okay
who's that
mommy that's mommy who's that
okay so she's definitely more interested
in the printer than the game that i have
provided for us
who's this that's maddie
who's that daddy who's that mummy
oh you printed an information
we printed some information here you go
that's for you
here let's play this fun game again nope
okay
well um i'm actually very impressed with
the quality
of these photos i that is an iphone
she's never seen anything like this
you'll say hi to the camera
can you say
you've hp the h how much do you think
i'm gonna have to pay her for
her participation okay here you go bryn
get the picture out get the picture
who is that oh
[Music]
truck
bye